My name is Alexander Pym
I'm an investigator here at K-RITH, KwaZulu-Natal Research Institute for
TB and HIV
So tell me about the project you're
working on to come up with better ways
to detect drug-resistant tuberculosis.
This morning we were at the hospital
where there's tons of MDR and XDR.
What's the problem that you're trying to
solve? So we want to get people on the
best treatment as quickly as possible.
And the problem is--the tests we have
available at the moment
take two to three months and are not very
well developed. And so for two or
three months
you have to treat patients with drugs
you don't know where they going to work
or not
you may be treating them with five drugs
at work when you may be treating them
with five that don't.
And as a result of this patients can die or
develop further
resistance. So we're trying to we're
trying to develop a rapid comprehensive
resistance test so a patient can walk
into the hospital
we can do the test and then within a
week or a few days we can give them the
best possible treatment
What's your strategy? How are you going
about developing something that doesn't
exist and what you have a lot of
equipment here that doesn't exist in
many places in Africa. (yeah) What're you  gonna do? We're working on the genetic code of
drug resistance.
So instead of growing the the bacteria
in the presence of drugs, which takes a
long time
we're trying to figure out the bar code
of resistance. Drug resistance arises
because of a mutation and then you use
sequencing equipment and you come up
with a barcode of
resistance. And if we can figure out where
the mutations are and who has them we'll
be able to tell immediately
who is resistant or not.  One of the
limitations of working on TB is you
have to work in a highly controlled
environment
Because TB is spread in the air. If I'm carrying culture with one of these
potentially deadly strains and I drop it
on the ground then I can infect you
One of the great things about K-RITH is
that we have some of the best BSL threes
in South Africa, if not in Africa
We're really focusing in an area where
we have XDR and the epidemics unfolding
in front of our eyes. So we're in a
great position to take something we
found in the lab and test it immediately
in the clinic. We can find a new mutation
we can figure out these strains are
resistant to this drug and then I can go
to King Dinuzulu Hospital on
Wednesday and say hey look guys
you shouldn't be --- you can't use capriomiacin in these patients because we
found out actually they're susceptible
or vice versa. You shouldn't be using
this drug because actually we it's
resistant -- we know these bugs are
resistant. And so we can get that
feedback between the lab and clinic
which is really what I think makes K-RITH  unique
We have some new drugs and we're
we're recycling some old drugs and I
think in the next two to three years we
will be able to dramatically shorten
treatment for drug resistance from 18
months to two years (what it is now) down
to we hope nine months or six months
that will really make a big impact on on
treating treating drug resistance
You need this new testing to go hand-in-hand with the roll out. Exactly, exactly
And particularly as we introduce new
drugs
we need to be able to rapidly monitor if
someone's become resistant to them and
that's where i think this these new
genetic tools really be of benefit as well.